joe biden's first foreign trip as
president marks a new phase
in the coronavirus pandemic and u.s
relations with the rest of the world
after a series of virtual meetings the
heads of the leading seven global
economies will meet face to face in the
uk
and this time there will be a u s
president who is less deliberately
disruptive
donald trump repeatedly confronted other
world leaders over trade
climate change and even the prospect of
bringing russia
back into the g7 group what
happened under the trump administration
is that it really shook a lot of
countries views
of the united states as a partner as an
ally
and part of biden's job is trying to
restore those ties restore that image of
the united states in the eyes of those
countries
president biden will also meet with nato
leaders an alliance donald trump talked
about leaving
he argued he was ready to push aside
traditions and fellow leaders
to deliver on his agenda trump spent
four years
tearing down nato criticizing um other
countries in europe
um suggesting the united states would be
better off without it why are we tied
down here etc etc
and so i think biden sees this as an
early opportunity
and an early public opportunity to
demonstrate his personal diplomatic
skills
the trump presidency questioned
challenged and upended
many traditional american political and
military positions
joe biden might be able to smooth over
the cracks
but he can't guarantee that things will
be that way after
the next election that relationships
that were taken for granted
will continue as they always have
biden's biggest challenge will be his
summit with russian president vladimir
putin a man he suggested is a killer
a man he believes is behind recent cyber
attacks on the u.s
a man who says america should prepare
for some uncomfortable truths at the
summit
there are no illusions about the state
of this u.s russia relationship so the
number one priority will be to at least
put this on a stable and predictable
track
needs to show that there are real costs
and that this is an administration that
will stand
up to russia's destabilizing behavior
world leaders hope their gathering will
send a message things are getting back
to
normal joe biden believes he is to send
the same message
after four years of donald trump
well alan fisher joins me now from the
white house alan i see biden now also
has a vaccine plan for the world
uh he's just left from joint air force
base
andrews heading to his summit
in the united kingdom he said as he left
that this was to show
china and russia that america and the eu
are united but there is a problem and
the problem is
over global vaccinations joe biden has
talked about waving global patents for
vaccinations the eu said hold on a
second that's a really bad idea first of
all it means that the people won't be
able to develop these vaccines for weeks
for months perhaps even years and also
it means that the intellectual property
rights for the drug companies
isn't protected they have an alternative
plan that they intend to show
to joe biden during the eu summit now
former leaders of many of the g7
countries have come together to say
that it's time for the eu and the g7 to
stand up and make sure
that poorer countries are vaccinated in
the words of one democratic congressman
while there is a threat
of covet somewhere in the world there's
a threat to covert
everywhere in the world and so they want
to make sure that both the eu
the g7 and the united states are on the
same page when it comes
to vaccinating the world joe biden as
you remember said that he intends to
give 25 million
that those doses of vaccine away by the
end of june
he'd like to see that number increase to
80 million as quickly as possible
it's a start for many but across the g7
and across the eu people believe that
there should be
a concerted plan to make sure that
poorer countries where vaccination rates
are two percent
or lower are given the chance of
catching up with the developed world
where these vaccines have been put
together
alan fisher there with all the latest
from biden's departure at the white
house thank you so much alan